that's great what's up guys welcome to
the just pearly things youtube channel
today i have a special guest on the
channel rebecca barrett
what's up
thank you for having me finally yeah
it's funny because like we met in person
and had like a four hour conversation
and then we never filmed we were
supposed to film but we never filmed
well i was out i was having so much fun
when we met i was like i don't even care
i'll film with her eventually you're
like you're like i'll have four coffees
just to stay here
why we gotta don't tell them that
[Laughter]
oh
no um it's funny because i was telling
you when i like met you that i feel like
we're very similar like reactors in the
man of sphere because we kind of reckon
we're kind of like represent like the
normal like girls
in the world that aren't like crazy
and unonly fans and stuff
yeah i agree uh it's kind of funny
because
um i was so i was talking to courtney
ryan um
this past week and shout out to courtney
i don't know if she's watching or
anything
but um we were talking about it i was
like man you know the thing that
influenced me the most to start a
youtube channel was
jordan peterson
talking to i think it was like an
interview i'll send it to you later but
he basically says
we need the normal women like the normal
girls to check their crazy sisters and i
used to be a crazy sister so i was like
if someone needs to get checked and
someone needs to get checked it's gonna
come from me because i was that crazy
sister who
was the feminist like
feminazi you know so i i was that person
so that was really like my big
inspiration of making more of these
videos but it's funny because
did you have the crazy like standards
like the 300k 200k engagement ring
like no
i didn't have those crazy standards
um i was more of like the men hating
type of girl so
so i
i fluctuated around the system or around
the feminism i call it like
there's different phases of feminism
there's like the pretty feminists that
kind of get away with saying like i need
a 200 000 ring
right or
i'm gonna sell myself on only fans like
that type of feminist and then you have
the other feminists that are like blue
haired feminists
and i was i kind of was in between both
because i did shave my head and dyed my
hair blue but i
also was that type of person was like
i'm pretty enough to wear
like i can get i can get by so
do you find that as feminists like get
older like they can get away with less
stuff is that like a thing do you think
yeah i think you know as the red pillars
like to say
once you hit that wall or once you
approach the wall it's really hard to
it's really it's very unforgiving right
so like
you know in your 20s you probably get
away with more you probably get away
with more like craziness you get away
with more like in relationships and in
dating and then once you hit
especially like your later 20s to your
early 30s i would say some women like to
push that to like
late 30s
um
you kind of start
realizing or hopefully coming to terms
with the fact that
life's not how you were playing it for a
while so really so you actually do think
that like the biological imperative like
sort of molded you to kind of go away
from that a little bit
yeah i mean i grew up in a very
traditional household my mom
took care of the household and my dad
went out and worked full-time like he
brought in the income so i grew up very
very traditional-minded so
when i decided to go down the feminist
route and i didn't even know that that's
what i was doing and i think that that's
the biggest trap or the the biggest
thing that women don't understand is
that
it's not like you choose to be a
feminist like
i think the media and social media and
you know tv all of that stuff plays a
huge impact
on us as women like growing up
and yeah i just you know i don't think
that women necessarily walk into and be
like yeah i'm going to be like i'm going
to hate men it's just like what the
narrative is and it's like i want to be
as cool as the narrative like i want to
i want to be like these other women who
are saying the same thing so it's more
of like
women trying to fit in if that makes
sense and not necessarily
well and it started for you because you
worked on a boat or i can't i can't
remember the exact job but you're an
engineer like in an all-male dominated
field you said that was where it started
or did i forget a phase
no so it kind of so it kind of started
in high school
so i
i don't
at my mom i actually was talking to my
mom about it today so
um
as i mentioned in previous videos and
stuff on my channel there had there was
infidelity in my house and so when i
started noticing that at a very young
age i was like i need to take care of
myself i can't rely on a man and that
was my conclusion based off of the
experiences that i had
then
i got propelled into or i propelled
myself into male dominated industries i
am an engineer i'm a mechanical engineer
like studied robotics and then i went to
go work for an oil company where i was
on an offshore rig
in the middle of nowhere for like a
month at a time or like i just i was
around men all the time so
when i started working with men it was
more of that like
i was doing it to myself i went into a
male-dominated industry thinking that
i'm gonna be this like
i don't know that i'm gonna like
experience a different type of world
like no they treated me like one of the
brothers like they treated me as one of
the guys they didn't say like oh here's
a dainty little girl like you wanted to
play with the boys play with the boys
like
that's what it was and so
i myself had a lot of anger towards them
but they treated me like
one of them and i earned respect with
them because
i you know
i
would shoot the [ __ ] with them i would
say like i would i would banter with
them right but then that also affected
my dating life where i was like okay
well i have this
i wouldn't call it like a luxe job but i
make
six figures at the age of like 20
something right
so then i was like this is translating
into my dating life because now i'm like
i can't date a guy that makes less than
what i do
or he's trash like that was my mindset
it wasn't
it wasn't that i was like
it i don't know it wasn't so that it was
so blatant in my face but that's just
what i came up with i was like well if i
make six figures he has to make six
figures too that only makes sense yeah
you know so
that's kind of how i saw it um
and then over time that slowly went away
yeah you get humbled by life
you get humbled so many times it was it
was funny because the thing that humbled
me the thing that humbled me was i left
that six figure job
um and then i started my own company and
i struggled for a long time people don't
understand that like entrepreneurs
struggle and they don't necessarily make
money right away
so i was like
i was like working at a restaurant job i
was doing all this other stuff to like
try to make money while running my
business and then i finally sold that
business and started i started another
one but like you go through these
failures and through these ups and downs
and you realize wow like
it's not all about money
and that's not and that's not how you
should be defined and i think as a
society we've put a lot of emphasis on
money as like as an indicator for
success and happiness and i think that's
a crack of crap
well and life is so long too you have no
idea where they're gonna be in 20 years
30 years like my dad said a lot of
people that seem like early winners like
aren't actually the winners like in the
long run because
you know success that comes like that
can go like that
yeah absolutely um garyvee says
something similar too you know he says
like a lot of these entrepreneur
entrepreneurs say the same thing it's a
marathon not a sprint if it's a sprint
for you it's going to
end very quickly and you have to
understand that it's like a long slog
and
you know once you get humbled by that
for sure because like working a
corporate job you get the kush
like paycheck and
you have to do like minimal work and
when you work for yourself you're
literally like i have to put food on my
own table and if i don't
get it together soon if i don't make
something happen soon i'm out of luck
like i have to go do something else so
that was like a
that was a big hit too but then that was
like a whole new level of feminism
because
when i moved to new york
when i started my companies my first
companies
this like
i i don't want to say it's all new new
york women are all new york like
entrepreneurs and stuff like that but
there's like a level of
of uh entitlement that comes with
with being a female entrepreneur and
being a minority entrepreneur
and
i fit those categories i'm a brazilian
woman i'm first generation american and
i'm
you know so all of those things were at
play so then everyone would tell me oh
you deserve this type of funding or you
need to do this because you deserve that
and i'm like for what for showing up
for being born a woman like a latina
woman like
but then at that point i was like okay i
drank the kool-aid so hard that i was
like yes i am entitled to all this stuff
so it created a whole new level of
entitlement not so much like the hating
men part but the more
of the
i deserved this even though i didn't
work for it type of entitlement if that
makes sense
no it totally does even on like the live
that i sent you the other day of mine
when i was like when it was it wasn't
like oh that would be super nice if he
bought me that ring it was like buy me
this i deserve your money and i was like
[Music]
i'm like baby girl listen i'm so sorry
to break it to you but you most likely
won't get a 200 000 ring
most likely
well and i asked like i asked my dad the
other day um i was just curious i was
like dad what's the most expensive gift
you bought mom
this is after 30 years of marriage it
was a hundred thousand dollar break so
half of that i'm like yeah hello guys
even guys that make money like they
don't want a girl that's like demanding
these crazy expensive gifts there's
these great crazy standards they'll give
it to you out of like being nice
sometimes but it's like i think the
entitlement where a lot of girls go
wrong
yeah and i think that
it's funny because like actually rich
people are very frugal
they don't spend money
just to spend money it's that like new
money
like that gatsby new money type of stuff
that they want to flash all of these
things so these guys that are paying
a crap ton of money to spoil their women
or take vacations
that just like we said
fast money leaves real quick like fast
money ends real fast so yeah if you want
to keep up with that lifestyle you have
to make more money and you have to give
up more like i'm so sorry to break it to
you but that's just how life works
well
well i think there's can you hear that
or not
i don't know what that was without it
it's my brother yelling oh next door
adam be quiet
i'm on an interview oh my god
oh well hello
don't stop
kind of move out soon
no um well i said there's a difference
between like money and like wealth like
you could have money and not be wealthy
but down generational wealth like
i think you kind of have to look at it
as like morally wrong to like spend on
like things that don't have an roi
consistently like here and there that's
fine but like like look at what's his
name the facebook guy
mark zuckerberg
t-shirt every day
yeah he wears this and that's what uh
was steve jobs wore the same outfit
every single day like
like mark zuckerberg doesn't care about
like gucci loafers he doesn't drive the
nicest car
he drives like a regular car and
wears regular clothes
yeah and he's filthy rich so
wait um so you said something earlier
that i had a question on you said you
your dad was unfaithful how
like and you knew like how did you know
as a kid
um the men are really
men are not that great at lying
[Laughter]
um no it's just like there was like a
lot of things that there were a lot of
signs and obviously my mom knew
and i could
you know i could pick things up along
the way
um i could tell who they were and this
was not just on one occasion this was on
multiple occasions
um and yeah it was just it was
devastating for my family it was
devastating for my
mom
but the thing is is like over time when
i grew up
and got to talk to my dad i realized
it's two sides it's not just one-sided
it wasn't just
he cheated and that was the end of that
it was
there were reasons why he cheated and
there was reasons why there was
infidelity and
lack of trust in the relationship
and i had to learn that from observing
and listening to both sides of the story
if i had just took taken my mom's side
the entire time i wouldn't have known
the full story and if i would have taken
my dad's side i would have known the
full story and so
it wasn't until like later on in life
like right before i got married where my
dad actually like sat me down and like
talked about this with me and um
unfortunately my dad passed away this
year so
so it was really it was good for me and
like
and for my family as like closure to
understand
why things happen the way that they
happened um
but you know like
we're we're humans we people make
mistakes people especially who've been
married for a long time i'm actually
making a full-blown video about this
tomorrow i'm launching it tomorrow about
cheating
um
in marriage and
in regular like dating relationships so
i'll go into that a little further
but but men and women cheat for very
different reasons so
so i'm
so and
if you don't want to like talk about any
of this on the air like feel free to
skip over it um
what did he say because i'm so curious
as to what like everyone always wants to
know like what goes on in the mind of a
cheater you know yeah
um i mean that's a very private thing
but but i will say like broadly
um if you
starve
if if you're a wife and you starve a man
of
physical touch
then um and like sex
then most likely they'll seek
sex in other places and vice versa if a
man is neglecting his woman if she's not
feeling appreciated or heard or seen in
the relationship she will seek an
emotional she will seek emotional
relationships and emotional intimacy
with someone else and that's why men and
women cheat differently because men
cheat for
gen this is generally speaking men cheat
for sex
because men need sex or men need
physical touch and relationships and
specifically in marriage and women on
the other hand crave emotional intimacy
and so
if you don't
meet that person's needs that person is
going to find it elsewhere so
well
no it's it's interesting you say that
because you know i always say like my
dad's like one of the
only like high value men or whatever
people don't think he like he exists and
people always think i'm lying but like
my dad's never cheated on my mom like
she's amazing
doesn't do that but one of the things my
mom told me
when i asked her what the um secret was
to a healthy marriage was to always just
say yes
that's what my mom that's what my mom
said on my like right before i got
married she's like when your husband
needs sex you give him sex i was like
okay
fair enough
[Music]
oh
yeah
men are like
and i'm sure a lot of guys also agree
men are very simple it's us as women who
are the most complicated
beings we you know men know how to
compartmentalize things they
compartmentalize sex they can
compartmentalize relationships work all
these other things as women everything
is like
intertwined mingled together mashed and
so
it becomes hard to
like
deserve compartmentalize that as a woman
if that makes sense yeah
you know what's one thing that i
realized um
not not until i was like a couple years
ago
men tell you exactly what they want we
just don't listen
are you kidding me like half of the cop
if women just read my comment section if
women just read
your comment section or anyone else in
the manosphere they would know exactly
what men want like it's really not a
riddle it's not like
a physics problem
it's not rocket science men need
a few things and if women started like
listening to that they might be
successful in relationships
shocking
well you have all these like female
mostly some male dating coaches telling
like women to play these games and i
think it's sometimes because like to be
honest like games work on women not not
all the time but a lot of women like the
games work on but like men aren't built
like us like you know what i mean like
they just they just look at like the
games and like playing hard to get all
that stuff is just like tiring
yeah i don't i don't really like games i
don't believe in games whatsoever i
think the best thing that the the reason
why
like first of all i was attracted to my
husband but the reason why i stayed with
my husband is because
we could both be transparent and not
play games and i felt comfortable with
him not playing games i was like this
man has integrity he has like morals and
values and he stands on those things but
these games is the games are what like
art is the issue i believe because
you know women are being told to have
game and play these games and men are
being told to play these games like you
go on tick tock and it's all bad advice
it's all like toxic tick tock advice i'm
like
why are
young people listening to this garbage
you know
and honestly like it's because people
crave this like toxic
these toxic relationships because that's
all they know that's all they've seen
that's all they've interacted with and
it's sad it's really sad to me and
that's why i
speak facts or truth and all this other
stuff and hopefully like more women are
coming to my channel but
it's really hard like women
don't like to hear the truth no
i'm like cis
you can live a better life if you just
listen to what i have to say stop doing
your thing like this is insanity doing
the same thing and expecting a different
result it hasn't worked for you for the
last eight
ten years
why are you still doing it like why are
you still listening to this garbage
information
what do you think is some of the worst
advice that you followed or
you like someone gave to you
uh
have as many guys in your roster as
possible
oh
i hate that i was like yo this is so
hard like i can't do this this is like
too much to navigate um and then
um
a lot of it a lot of it was like around
cheating like i never i
have never cheated on anyone
um
i've had people
cheat
on their significant other with me not
knowing that
i did that you know i was like wait what
like come to find out after the fact
um so i never was like that cheating
type obviously because of my past
i don't believe in cheating i don't
condone it
um but yeah just like
i don't know but it's also different
because i'm 32
so dating
to me was dating like
even five years ago was different than
dating today like it's a whole new world
out there and
honestly i feel for a lot of people like
men and women going through this because
it is not the same playing field at all
like i was on tinder and i was on bumble
and i was on hinge and all of those
things before
but what you're seeing today is like
like level 20
crazy like i don't understand what
happened to
dating
well i think people are just afraid of
being like used and being hurt and
looking stupid
like i think i think women don't we
don't want to be used for our bodies
right and then we they don't want to be
used for their resources
and i feel like like it's both people
that are just like
like have a roster so that way like in
case one person does you dirty you have
four more it's like out of like a fear
and like i'm scared mindset which really
you know isn't good to go into dating
yeah i feel like a lot of people are
walking into dating with this fear
mentality it's coming from a place of
hurt it's coming from a place of
like
trauma unresolved things that they
haven't
you know worked through or even gone to
counseling for this is why i'm a huge
proponent of counseling as well because
it's really important that people start
putting in the work for themselves i
feel like if you want someone
if you want this ideal person you need
to be that ideal person like you need to
work on yourself you need to strive for
that like if you want a fit man
you can't be sitting at home eating like
a bag of donuts or
a tub of ice cream like
you're not gonna get that guy looking
like that like you have to go to the gym
you have to meet him where he is and i
tell and i tell
guys to i'm like you know where you want
to meet girls target
marshalls tj maxx home goods that's
where all the girls are at we're all at
this place
or even even the did you say the gym
because i feel like the gym would be a
really great way to
you know meet girls
yeah i mean the gym is a great place
like if you're working on yourself
right like that person will see you
every day like in new york i i had like
i had the same train that i went on and
i saw this similar people not it was not
always the same people but for the most
part like you walk the neighborhood you
see kind of the same people you eat at
the same restaurants
at some point you'll run into someone
that you'd be like hey i've seen you
before like
like how do you like this coffee shop or
whatever i like what people are so
scared to talk to each other and like
actually have
a meaningful conversation everything is
like these quick things that's why i
don't really like online dating either
because it's so
i don't know it's like so superficial
like oh he doesn't take that box off and
he doesn't look like that or you know
if honestly i tell this to my husband
i'm like if we had met on an online like
dating profile i don't know if i would
have swiped right on you but like
meeting him in person
and seeing like the full level of like
swagginess and like
getting like the vibe right in front of
me i was like oh he's
he's cute
you know
he's like real hot and then he opened
his mouth and his voice was so deep i
was like all right like sold and this is
something that um
i wanted to bring up too because i feel
like so many people disregard
the voice and especially for men
that is like if a guy is so if a guy is
smoking hot like a level nine right like
a nine
body nine everything right and then he
opens his mouth and he sounds like a
chipmunk or something
or
he has nothing good to say
he has nothing good to say or he's like
scatter brain or has no game like
nothing just like sounds like an idiot
i'm not gonna date him like i would
rather go for like a six with a hot
voice
than a nine with like a crappy like
little girl voice like ill gross yeah
that's what that's what i was saying on
that black pill channel i was on like
vocal tonality can do so much for a guy
so much it can also ruin a guy like he
can bring him down oh my gosh yeah i was
talking to my husband because he was
telling me that his stepdad taught him
how to speak with like through his
diaphragm
and um
and like speak from his belly
essentially because men have to men's
like if you you can teach a boy how to
speak like a man like when they're
developing
um and they speak from their stomach and
that's why he has such a deep voice and
i'm like that is
the best thing your stepdad ever taught
you
they should teach that at like pickups
like instead of instead of like pick up
boot camps do like vocal tonality
because
yeah
that would help so much to be honest
yeah i feel like a guy can like really
up his game just by
yeah increasing his vocal tonality
because so many women
i've i've seen
i've seen women date these guys that
yeah they might be hot but then they
start opening their mouth i'm like ugh
you listen to that like
how do you guys have sex like
this is bad like this is bad bad
like uh okay whatever you're into
so um one thing that i i really wanted
to ask you about um could you talk about
your like journey um from feminist to
christian it was christian yeah right
yeah
um so
so that's another thing too so i've been
a christian my whole life like i grew up
in the church
so
um growing up very traditional
in a traditional household also
attending church on a regular basis like
i
i i'd say that i was like
a prodigal daughter in a sense and what
that means is like i knew faith and then
i walked away from my faith and then i
came back to my faith and so
that i think having a level of faith
growing up really helped as like a basis
as a standard of morality for myself
because when i would see things in the
world like as a feminist
i would question things like i would
question why these things happen or why
women respond like that but i would
still do it right like i would still
participate i would still go to the
rallies i would still
you know
do all of this did you go to the [ __ ]
walk
okay i don't know i don't know
i mean i i'm just wondering how far you
took it no but i did go to like like i
did go to marches i did go to i did i
did participate in um what's it called
like i did participate in groups like in
in female and female-centric groups
where like we would advocate for
entrepreneurs uh
for funding i was like
on certain um i wouldn't say their
boards but on advisory boards and stuff
for those type of things so i was a huge
advocate for
especially women in the workplace and
stuff like that listen i still am like
if you want to
live your life working full-time and
being that
by all means do it like but here's the
thing this is where i kind of reel it
back
like
we all make
decisions we all
like
we all make a decision right and there's
consequences to all of our
actions so either they're good
consequences or bad consequences and
that's dependent on how you look at it
right like
the response that that happens to you so
you have to live with the consequences
of whatever decision that you make and
so if you want to work
and be a ceo and like be on the board of
whatever then do it like good for you
but if you also want children and have a
family like you have to understand like
you can't have your cake and eat it too
so
that's where i kind of came to the
realization is like i can't have my cake
and eat it too i had a woman
a real estate investor who sat down with
me and she's like rebecca do you want my
life
and she explained to me what her life
was she was saying like i travel all
around the world i do whatever i want i
have a husband but i have no children
she's like i'm 50 something years old i
have no children i have no
nothing i have no semblance of like that
as a family right i have a husband we
live a really good life together and i
make a crap ton of money okay
and so she she asked me i'm like you
have to make a decision do you want this
or do you want
family and a husband and all that other
stuff because at some point like you
cannot have your cake and eat it too
like this is the lie and the myth that
women have been told they can have
everything and anything that they want
and there are no consequences to that
like
and that's the problem with feminism
it's like taken to a point where
feminism was originally for
equal rights right like
men and women having equal rights
on a litigation and
on a legal level we've accomplished that
like we've accom
we have accomplished that and if you
look at swedish countries or if you look
at nordic countries where um
people where they have this egalitarian
society
you see the most differences between men
and women right like men choose more um
more
like engineering architecture roles
things like that and women are choosing
nursing being teachers and stuff so
obviously you're not going to get paid
the same like a teacher
and an engineer are not going to be paid
the same so
in those countries you you see a big
difference and a big discrepancy
in
like
female and male characteristics and what
we actually want and desire now going
back to my life
right i had to make that i had to come
to terms i was 28 years old
i was like
i
could run this company i could continue
to do this i can continue to like live
this life right but i want a husband i
eventually want a husband i eventually
want kids like i don't want kids right
this second but i eventually want kids
and so you know when i did meet my
husband
i like and we decided to take the next
step i went through intense
marriage premarital counseling with my
husband like intense premarital
counseling with my husband and so
that was also done with the church that
was done alongside the church and the
man who married us our premarital
counselor
also
was our pastor who married us like he
had to give the green light in order for
us to get married and i think that was
so important because
we could we would have rushed marriage
we'd we would have had a short
engagement we would have had like
we probably would have
skipped
half of the hard stuff that we went
through
um
and that's just the reality and we had
to go through a lot and luckily you know
the one thing that i will say is like
when i met my husband
i knew from the beginning like from the
first interaction that we had like
not the first interaction but like the
first date that we were on what his
morals what his values were so he was a
christian he went to church he believed
a lot of the same things that i did and
so
that to me was a good sign because
it didn't matter how much money he made
it didn't matter all that stuff because
he aligned with my values and morals
whereas like i dated ceos i've dated you
know hedge fund hedge fund managers and
all this other stuff like i dated pretty
successful people that didn't align with
my values and things fell apart really
quickly because
i didn't
believe certain things that they
believed you know so
i think that
people
forego like forget to think about
what our value like what your value is
and what you want to
look for in a in a potential partner in
that way but yeah like you know i i've
always been a christian and i grew up in
the church and
once i kind of came back and my
counselor really sat me down he said
rebecca your marriage is gonna fall
apart if you continue to act this way if
you continue to be like thinking that
these like
in this ideology you know where it's
like you control the relationship like
that's not biblical that's not
how god designed it and
i was like okay i gotta swallow this i
gotta like
get my head right and i have to
you know work with my
then fiance right so
we worked through a lot like he came in
he had a lot of things that he had to
work on i had a lot of things that i had
to work on but we worked on things
individually and together and we got
through a lot and we built our tool
belts of
tools for
when more stuff hits the fan
later on down the road
how long
how long was like the premarital
counseling
so uh we were to so i'll give you like a
brief background so we were together for
a year we got engaged after a year and
then we had a year-long engagement
before we got married so all of our
anniversaries are in october so
we're coming up on our uh one year
of marriage this year which is super
exciting
um
but
but yeah it was a year-long engagement
and it was a year-long it was actually
more than a year of premarital
counseling because we
we had to
talk to him he had to vet us before we
even
he before he even wanted to take us on
as like clients and stuff so
wait so um
can you talk about you guys ended up
waiting like taking sex off the table
for a while right mm-hmm um
tell me about that
yeah so
just see this is like a touchy subject
i've talked about it very openly on my
on my um youtube like my husband and i
both
did a video on it and this is you know i
get a lot of flack for this because yes
we both had sex before marriage we both
weren't virgins before
we were married um but what happened was
is that
when i knew that he was the one for me
sex
sex before marriage was
how do i put this like
i felt
dirty
and not because of and not because of
him
but because of the
past trauma and the past
um
partners that i've been with that i had
to kind of release those soul ties to
before giving him like everything
because
sex in marriage and intimacy in marriage
is like a whole new
level of amazingness like it's something
that i can't explain like
the sex we have today and the sex we had
before it was very like lustful before
and we also um we both had pornography
issues um that we both are now like
pornography free and
uh my husband actually has an
accountability person that he ha that um
he works with and i also have some like
i have an accountability partner so um
we had to really make that decision for
our relationship
and it's a tough one because like once
you have sex
with that person it's really hard not to
continue to have sex with that person if
that makes sense and it makes it even
harder
like knowing that you're waiting
to have sex with that person on your
wedding day but
what's interesting is like i i'm so
grateful that we did it because we
learned intimacy and we learned how to
grow closer together without sex
being the main um
like the main factor for intimacy and we
had to grow and learn with like learn
from each other and
it was probably the most most growth
we've ever made um in a short period of
time
and
it was very hard don't get me wrong like
it was so difficult and people give us
flack for it all the time like how could
you have sex before and then stop having
sex like it's your fault you're the one
that uh wanted him to stop having sex
with you and all this other stuff and
here's the thing like he could have
equally he could have made the decision
to continue to want to have sex and i
would have been like okay
i can't do that like i see marriage and
we sat through that we had a lot of
courageous conversations with our
counselor we had a lot of
problems like it wasn't
it wasn't like okay we're not gonna have
sex
cool like
we both were very like lustful for each
other we wanted to be like intimate with
each other so it was very hard like i
had to say no a lot of the times and
it wasn't easy for me because i know
that men
need physical touch i know that men need
sex in relationships but
but we made that decision together
um
and it was one of the best decisions
we've ever made and now sex is amazing
sex is like
a whole new world and
and it's less shameful like it's less
it's less of that burden because i don't
think men necessarily understand this
for women like i think that women
i think that women have been conditioned
to
forget
or how do i say this to kind of um
i want to say this in the best way
possible so women have been conditioned
to see sex like men see sex
so
um
so as a woman like
biology let's just break it down like
we receive a lot when
a man puts it inside of us right so yeah
so we tend to carry a lot of um
baggage like emotional baggage because
we receive
things like we receive it right well men
while men give it that's why it's a lot
easier for men to disconnect after sex
women release a lot more oxytocin during
sex than men do
hence why we crave the cuddle like to
cuddle and to snuggle and all that stuff
like we want that emotional attachment
we
have that emotional attachment because
of that and so we've been conditioned as
a society as women to be told you need
to you can have sex with whoever you
want you can have sex as many times as
you want you can do whatever you want
right but like
our
our soul our
brain
and our hormones know that that's not
good for us right and so
i think
i think that's
why i carried a lot of shame
going into my marriage or going into my
engagement because
i was like i'm holding on to like all
these
people that i had sex with before
that
don't make this experience
like
pleasurable or don't make this
experience meaningful not that it wasn't
meaningful but it wasn't like i felt
more shame than happiness after sex if
that makes sense yeah you know
well i think like the development of
birth control just isn't like natural
you know what i mean like we're meant to
have kids like a decade earlier and like
naturally if nature like ran its course
i'm not saying it's like a bad thing
altogether but
i think like
that's almost why
like we have we have more partners now
because clearly we're older when we get
married and i just i don't think like
women are meant for that you know like
naturally yeah i agree i agree
definitely like birth control
manipulates the hormones in a woman's
body like i never
i never had a good reaction to birth
control i went on a lot of different
types of birth controls because i i
wanted i wanted that like life of you
know
what they tell us freedom like
and so
i i tried a lot of them i've done like i
did the iud i did all of them right so
none of them worked for me and
i
like i attribute that to like my
biology doesn't like agree with
that type of like fake hormone that
they're trying to give you and i think a
lot of women have problems with birth
control as well but
some women are more sensitive to that
than others i'm a very sensitive person
when it comes to like my body and what
what goes into my body and whatnot i
don't take medications
um and so yeah birth control was
difficult and i think it like obviously
birth control tricks your brain into
thinking that you're pregnant once a
month or whatever yeah or not pregnant i
don't know but it's very bad for you as
a woman because it's
you can like skip your periods and your
periods are the number one indicator
that you're like fertile and that you're
like and that you can like
carry a pregnancy and that your like
hormones are
leveled out and stuff and so when women
start taking birth control at the age of
like 15
right i don't
like listen i'm not gonna say take birth
control off the table because i think we
would be in a very
dark bad place
if birth control was off the table but i
also think that it's a personal choice
and
it goes back to that like
you have to you have to take
responsibility and accountability for
your own
body and for your own choices like i
chose not to take birth control and
yeah that's it oh i didn't realize you
didn't take birth control through all of
that oh yeah no
i tried i
i
that was the thing is like i tried so
hard
but didn't get too far
wait so um a lot of
like people this is my biggest
disagreement in the mana sphere like a
lot of people would see
like your situation as um
like selling a used car for like new
prices yeah you know and i just think
like it's not really fair you know like
i think people can make mistakes and try
to make better decisions moving forward
um and i don't it doesn't seem like your
husband like felt like that was the case
i mean i mean he came with his own
baggage too right like i was paying full
price for
his
his
situation too
um yeah i mean i get that all the time
like that's probably one of the biggest
uh
comments that i get on that video is
like oh she's he bought a used car for
full price i'm like listen we all come
with a level of baggage we all come with
problems none of us are perfect beings
none of us like i'm so sorry to break it
to you everybody say you're perfect but
you're not and so and again
uh the women
this is what i find fascinating
um
you know the women that you're saying
that you wouldn't pay full price for and
like have high body counts they had to
sleep with someone like there was a man
on the other side of that yeah
i mean like men aren't perfect beings
either
listen
we are not perfect at all we are
if you think you're perfect
i'm sorry you live in la la land like
it's just it's just the way it is and
my husband is in recovery like we
uh he's in he's in recovery so he has a
pass too right like it's not like he's
he came like with a halo over his head
yeah and whatnot and
that's why we go through therapy that's
why we have counseling that's why we
have therapists today
well i think sometimes like in the
manners and it's hard because i think
the manosphere like the red pill is
genuinely a reaction to feminism
like where feminism just hates on men
all day so this is the reaction but like
sometimes in the middle sphere i'll just
see like oh like this woman's trash like
or um only fans models or you know this
this this is a problem and you kind of
have to remind people like one people
aren't perfect and two like there's
pretty normal like regular girls
yeah
yeah i agree with that like um
the biggest misconception is that
there's no normal girls out there and
the pro the thing is is like the people
who have the loudest voices are the
minority so what you're seeing on social
media is
these loud voices saying like
all these women
you know are paying or are asking guys
to pay for sex like i mean
listen if you live in maybe l.a or like
these parts of the country yeah that
might be the case right but there are a
lot of good men and women out there that
still exist
that
are not tainted by this but you know we
see in this in the rp community and in
the general manosphere i think is like
yeah it is a response to feminism
and men like here's the thing men just
want to feel hurt they want a space to
feel seen and they also don't want to
disappear off of the planet like i agree
like that's amazing and they can empower
they can empower each other but um also
too on the flip side is that
like is there actual male improvement
like when you see the roommates they
preach that they are male improvement
that they are not necessarily rp
and it's true because
um the the biggest clicks or like the
the number one clicks are like only
fan's model is delusional and like asks
for like 200 thousand dollar ring and
brittany renner like that's all the
headline stuff right but like actual
male improvement is important for men
they need to know how to be like how to
improve themselves how to be better men
but also too
like women need to more women need to
call more women out like that's why i
have my channel because
we have a lot of crazy women out there
like a lot and
and to be honest they don't listen to a
lot of men they don't want to listen to
men they
get better there's better responses from
women trust me i get a bunch of hate
all over like all over the place from
men and women
but
someone needs to be out here spreading
the truth some
normalcy into the space
and i i feel like i have a very balanced
view right like i understand why men
feel the way that they feel and i
understand
why women act the way that they act
you know i'm a general observationalist
like that's what i do and so when you
observe the space this is what you do as
well you observe the space and then you
make your conclusions based off of what
you observe like
like you know
so
but it takes a person it takes a person
to like step into the other side and to
like come to the table and actually have
a conversation whereas like a lot of
women don't
know
wanna have the conversation and and i
think now too like men like men who go
their own way
they
you know what makes me sad is like they
work so hard
to earn a living for themselves and a
good life for themselves but they won't
have a legacy to leave behind they won't
have a son or they won't have children
to leave that legacy behind so then
what's the point of
of working so hard what's the point of
doing all of this
you know self-improvement and betterment
and all this other stuff if there's
nothing to leave
behind like
like
you know in the past
men
men have
wanted sons so that they can keep their
their generational line going like
that's the whole point of generational
wealth right to leave something behind
to your children
so
we are seeing we are seeing like
the lowest birth rates that we've ever
seen we are seeing
women and men stepping away from each
other and it's really sad you know it
boggles me the more and more women that
i meet that say they don't want kids or
don't see themselves having kids like
one of my really good um female friends
like
and she would be a great mother if she
wanted to be like she was telling me
that she doesn't want to have kids
because it would be so bad on her body
i'm like girl age is going to get you
anyway you can buy new boobs if you need
to
yeah
what is that like you literally get to
create life like how do you not want
that
yeah yeah you know i think it comes from
a i think it comes from a place of fear
because i used to say that as well
especially like in your 20s like the
last thing you're thinking about is
children because that's again what
society is perpetuating for women
they're selling women the the lie the
myth that you can wait as long as
possible to have children and everything
will be okay
what happens um usually you have to
freeze your eggs you have to then do ivf
and other treatments along the way and
at the end of the day women are in their
mid to late 30s are spending
thousands of dollars on these treatments
to then get that pregnancy that they
want right
but if they had even taken some
preventative measures by doing early
testing in their 20s like you don't have
to know that you want kids right now
like you don't have to want kids at the
specific moment but knowing what your
body is doing
i believe is so important because
you you come you can come to find out in
your 20s like in your late 20s that your
eggs are less viable like that you don't
have enough eggs
even to produce a viable pregnancy and
so i think that's a huge myth um that
women keep getting fed is this idea of
like
i don't need kids i don't want kids it's
you know and then again it comes from a
place of fear right like oh this is
going to ruin my body or oh i don't want
them to grow up into a world like this
and all that other stuff and what my
response is is that uh you can
you can educate them correctly and
you know you can
teach your children
through like your morals and values what
you believe in and hopefully that
they'll turn out okay
and on top of it like
hormonally and biologically once that
kicks in for you
even if it's like in your late 30s
going into your
40s i'm sorry but mother nature has
she's not
nice okay
when i turned
like right when my husband and i got
married
um
i was getting to the point where like my
sister had just given birth or she was
giving birth and i was like oh my gosh
like i'm starting to want kids but then
i'm like
uh it's too soon like i just got married
like it's gonna come too soon like i
want to have at least some
at least some like
time with my husband
but yo when
when the timer sets
oh my gosh that's all i was thinking
about i was like i need a child right
this second if i don't have a child
right now i'm gonna lose my actual mind
and that's unfortunately happening to a
lot of women and like here's the thing
um
you know you can't you can't change your
biology
i know people are going to be like well
i don't want to get political with it
but like you can't change the fact that
you would want children okay like
and some and here's the thing not all
women not all women want that you can be
the you can be the
exception to the rule but for the most
part
do you think sometimes i think that
women who say they don't want that say
that because they don't think they can
get it
yeah
like it's fear-based yeah so like i'll
see girls say oh i don't know if i want
kids
but you know they're 31 32 no viable
prospect of a husband so like if you say
you want that then you have to admit to
yourself that it might not happen
yeah it's it's very hard it's
it's hard for people to realize the
truth right like it's a hard pill to
swallow hence why these
pills exist right it's a hard pill to
swaddle reality
and
when reality kicks in
you know you can live in denial all you
want um it's not gonna better it's not
gonna
it's not to improve your life living in
denial right um but but yeah like it
comes to the point where like you have
to you have to
it's like the first step right you have
to admit there was wrong you have to
admit
a place of wrong and a
a place of like okay
this is not working for me you know but
some people need to hit rock bottom and
then double rock bottom and then triple
rock bottom and then sometimes they get
it
so um we kind of left off where you were
getting the counseling how has marriage
been for you
marriage has been awesome but it's also
been like so again i lost my dad this
year so
i didn't like people say oh rebecca like
you're in your honeymoon face i'm like
i've lived
i've lived like 20 years of marriage in
one year of marriage okay like and and
that's why i think premarital counseling
was so
benefici beneficial to
our relationship and to other people's
relationships because you get the tools
that you need to um get through these
situations like when my dad passed away
this year
we were literally
two or three months married
he passed away in january and i was
devastated like gutted like i'm still i
still
i mean i'm not over it obviously like
grief is just very different um
but
you know as someone who i had to take
care of my family i had to be the rock
for my my like
family family but when i came home i was
like i need you like i'm
i'm a mess like i was a mess right
um so marriage overall has been
pretty amazing but also have come with a
lot of challenges you know outside
things not with our personal marriage
like we've grown so much this year
um
and it's due to like all of these things
that happen right like my dad passing we
were pregnant with our first child i'm
having a little girl
um and so
and so there's so many like big life
things that have happened this year that
has made it so wonderful but also like
so hard at the same time um
yeah overall it's been amazing and i
can't wait i feel like i was talking to
him the other day about this i was like
i feel like we've been married for like
30 years
but i know obviously it's like been one
year of marriage but it's crazy because
like i know people that have ended
marriages within seven months within
like a year or even like
right after that so
you know they say the first year of
marriage is amazing but also but also
one of the toughest years of marriage
and i will attest to that i'm like
yo i've we've literally had everything
like the kitchen sink thrown up thrown
at us at this point so
did you guys live together before you
were married
um
no so
well for for a little bit of time
actually so i will say that um for
the pandemic he moved down here for six
months before we got married uh but we
lived on twin beds so
um it was
it was pretty
it was a different this is your first
like real apartment and like uh yeah
this is our first yeah and i we had to
learn how to live together
oh my gosh let's just say that
that
it is a doozy like but that's the beauty
of it right like that's the beauty of
marriage and that's the beauty of living
together after marriage right like
i the only reason why my my husband
moved down to florida for the pandemic
is because we were scared he was gonna
get stuck in new york at some point like
before the wedding so my parents are
like he needs to come down asap like
he needs to come down so we technically
did live together for six months but uh
we lived in separate like beds in
separate bedrooms um
but yeah marriage
living together living with someone you
learn
their habits like
my husband loves to like take off his
socks
when he sits on the couch so i find like
his socks under the couch
i find like piles and piles of socks
under the couch and i'm just like okay i
just gotta live with it this is what he
does like i can't get mad at him i'm
sure i do things that he gets upset at
me about but that's the beauty of like
living and
like doing life together with the person
like i don't know it's beautiful
do you guys have more traditional roles
in the home like do you [ __ ] clean
okay yeah my husband
i don't he he knows how to microwave i'm
just kidding
so it's funny because like he lived in
new york like
he's was born in or not he wasn't born
there but he was raised in new york so
like if he wanted food
he would literally go to the bodega and
like pick up food like my husband lived
off of like bodega food and like other
and like just
if he needed food he would go get food
outside like never cooked really
um
but yeah i do a lot of the cooking i do
a lot of the cleaning i do a lot of the
household stuff because i like to do the
household stuff
and i like my house super clean and i
like it organized and he is not that
type of person so
um so yeah and then he
and then he goes off to work like he's
been at work since
8 a.m this morning so
he works full like a full day and he
brings home
most of the money i bring home some
money from youtube but he brings home
the majority of the money and we like we
like it that way but we also talked
about it before marriage
what our roles were
gonna be before we got married and i
think that's really important people
like neglect that right um
and once we have kids it's gonna change
again like
i you know we've already started talking
about what um
what we
like what roles we want to play
um
in parenting and stuff like i realized
that i have to this baby is going to be
latched on to me for like six months
uh for the first six months of its life
um but yeah like what are what are
individual roles raising children what
our roles are together what our roles in
the household and eventually like what
my role here on youtube is gonna be
because
um
once i have this baby i don't know if
i'm going to be producing the same
amount of content that i do
on a regular basis i do like family
vlogs oh my gosh yeah i know right or
like the baby is like going to be like
i'm gonna be breastfeeding the baby like
hey guys welcome back to my channel
wait um so did you have did you give up
like some of your career at all when you
got married did you or was this what you
were doing before
um no so so
yes i gave up some of my career but it
was because my career that company was
ending
it still runs um
like remotely like i don't have to run
the business full time the same way
um but yeah like the business runs but
i've always been an entrepreneur and
like i started making i started youtube
in 2018 people don't realize that they
think that i like
blew up overnight which i didn't at all
um i've been on youtube for a while now
making hair videos and other types of
content and it wasn't until
recently where i was like i really want
to change up my content because of that
jordan peterson
um
video and other influences in my life as
well
um
and yeah
it's i will see what happens with
youtube i'm excited about the growth
that's been happening on my channel i'm
excited that people um
like the content that i put out there
and i really genuinely want to help
people i want to help women primarily is
my goal right i stumbled into the
manosphere yeah by accident
by accident um
and some people think that i'm like
um
some people think that i'm there to to
be the spokesperson for the manosphere
i'm not like i'm learning the same way
as you pearl like
you know
taking one piece of information at a
time but at the same time it's like i've
learned so much through counseling i've
learned so much through
um just my personal experiences and
i don't want women to make the same
mistakes that i
made and i'm trying to like
get them while they're early like
younger in their 20s
maybe i should go on tick-tock
so um what advice do you have for young
women
i'm 24 so i'm like basically i'm here
what you got rebecca
i would say i would say first of all um
like
start
one don't be promiscuous don't sleep
around with anyone
that's probably like right now one of
the biggest things i want women to
understand like
your value doesn't come from another
person like your value comes from what
work you put into yourself
and i believe your value my value comes
from god so
that's how i see it so when you are
being told that your value comes from
another man or from um other women or
stuff like that like that's not good
right and or your validation comes from
social media or
only fans and things like that that's
not that's not good so
um yeah
don't don't be promiscuous pearl like
keep it locked keep it low
keep it loaded okay
that was that's one of the biggest
things i want more women to know yeah
and then also and then also too like if
you want the man that you
if you want the man of your dreams or
whatever
i first of all i say rip up your list
whatever your list is just rip it up
because my husband definitely didn't
meet my list of things that i had and
that i wanted in a relationship
he had the he had my short list which is
being a christian having the same morals
and values that i had but
like everything else just rip up your
list
the list is not necessary work on
yourself if you want a fit man if you
want like all of these different things
right you got to work on yourself you
can't just say like well i'm just going
to sit here and expect the ups guy to
show up and like maybe i'll date him
no like you have to put yourself out
there at some point and you have to work
on yourself and it's a constant thing
like we constantly have to work on
ourselves we constantly have to be
better and that's who we're going to
attract we're going to attract
you know
that like the type of person that we put
that we like the hard work that we put
into it so
that's another thing as well
and if you want to find guys go to the
gym at a gym
gym coffee shops are great
uh
you know men
fine you're not like you're telling me
i'm not going to meet a man of character
at the club at four in the morning no
probably not
not as far
i'm just playing
probably not at the bar either and yeah
like i think entrepreneurs and cars said
the same thing like find a hobby that
you like and if like men like the same
hobby
then that's cool too like if you like to
go to the shooting range or if you like
axe throwing or if you like
i don't know
but if you want to find a man you have
to put yourself out there you can't just
be sitting at home like eating
ice cream out of a tub and like watching
fairy tale movies like that's your
prince charming is not going to knock on
your door
uh well thank you so much for coming on
the channel this was so fun i definitely
have to have you back on again i feel
like this was much overdue
i knew the same i was like dang i was
like if we could just translate our
coffee dates into this like all the time
it would be good content
no i was thinking that when i get to
england my stuff's gonna be a lot more
consistent so who knows maybe we could
do like a weekly show or something yeah
that would be so cool we need to do
something for sure because this is
always fun having a conversation with
you yeah well i like it too because i
think our values are very similar like
when it comes to like you know just
being a christian and like you know not
being too red pill
there's a balance like we have to
establish a balance right like you can't
be this i tell people like don't be too
extreme like ex these extremes is what
makes us further apart just like in
everything right like you look at the
political state of the world right now
like
these extremes keep us further and
further divided from each other so
if we want to come together we have to
be balanced at some point we have to
come to some sort of middle ground and i
like it i think we both are middle
ground people yeah
okay guys do not forget to subscribe to
not only my channel but rebecca's too
um if they look up just rebecca barrett
you'll be the first one that comes up
um don't forget like the video if you
like this type of content and i will
talk to you guys next time
bye guys